an elementary idea that gets you a long
way in counting things is this idea of
counting with by CH actions which is
counting one thing by counting another
and we can illustrate that by example
let's begin with looking at some stuff
that is easy to count using just the
simple sum and product rules so suppose
that I'm trying to count passwords this
is a contrived oversimplified example
but it gives you the idea and this is
what I mean by a password a password is
a sequence of characters that are either
letter letters or digits subject to the
constraints that they are supposed to be
between 6 & 8 characters long they're
supposed to start with a letter and
they're case-sensitive so you can tell
the difference between uppercase and
lowercase letters so let's define the
set L of all the letters uppercase and
lowercase together and let D be the set
of digits from 0 through 9 then we said
that passwords are supposed to be
between 6 & 8 words long but it's a
little bit easier actually just use
length as a parameter so let's think
about words of length n that satisfy the
password conditions so PN is going to be
the length n words starting with a
letter and so which is one of the
password constraints so we can express
that as a length n word can be broken up
into the first character which is an L a
paired with the rest of the word the
remaining n minus 1 characters and the
remaining n minus 1 characters can be
either l's or these so the length n
passwords can be expressed as the
product of l with the nth power of L
Union D that is L Union V cross L Union
D cross L unity n minus 1 times well now
we have an easy way to count this
because the size of this product by the
product rule is the size of L times the
size of L Union D to the N minus first
power
and of course L union D since letters
and digits don't overlap by the sum rule
the size of them is just L plus D and so
I get this nice formula that it's 52
letters a times 52 letters plus 10
digits raised to the n minus first power
okay what about the passwords
well the passwords were then p6 Union p7
Union p8 and since words of length six
don't overlap with words of length seven
or eight this is a disjoint Union and
therefore the total number of passwords
as specified is simply the size of p6
plus the particle size of p7 plus the
size of PA there's the formula when I
plug in and it turns out to be a good
sized number 19 times 10 to the 14th
okay that's one simple example where I'm
translating a spec into something that I
can express easily as a as a products
and sums and disjoint sums of stuff that
I already know the size of let's just do
another example suppose that I want to
count the number of four-digit numbers
so the the elements of these four digit
numbers are 0 through 9 there are 10
possibilities with at least one 7 the
number of four-digit sequences of digits
that have at least one 7 in them and one
way to count is I can make it a sum of
different four-digit numbers containing
1 7 depending on where the first 7 is if
there's at least one 7 is a first 7
that's the well ordering principle being
applied so if we let X abbreviate any
digit there 10 possible values of x and
o represent any digit other than 7 so
there's nine possible values of O then
the words that start with 7 can then be
followed with any to any three digits so
seven xxx is one possible pattern when
the first occurrence of 7 is first
another possible pattern is when you
have a digit that's not 7 followed by a
7 this one 7 occurs second followed by
anything at all
likewise here as
and occurs third in here seven occurs
fourth now these individual patterns are
easy enough to count using the product
rule because here I have to count how
many triples of any digits are there
well there's ten digits so it's 10 cubed
here how many sequences of where the
first choice is 9 and the second two
choices are the 10 and it's 9 times 10
squared here it's 9 squared times 10 and
here it's 9 cubed these are disjoint
because they're distinguished by where
the first 7 occurs and so I just add
them up and I get this number it's not
especially interesting but it's 34:39
okay so that's an exercise in counting
something by somewhat ingeniously
breaking it up into a sum of disjoint
things that are themselves easy to
easier to count there's another way
that's another standard trick that comes
up in combinatorics so how do you count
the number the the sequence of four
digit numbers with with at least one
seven by counting their complement count
the numbers of four digit numbers that
don't have any sevens and simply
subtract that number the number of four
digit numbers with no sevens from the
total number of four digit numbers and
that's going to be the numbers that are
left over that have one seven now the
number of four digit numbers is easy to
count and it will turn out that the
number of four digit numbers with no
sevens is also really easy to count
because the number of four digit numbers
is ten to the fourth and the number of
four digit numbers with no sevens
there's nine possible choices for each
of the remaining digits so it's just the
digits 0 through 9 leaving out 7 to the
fourth power or 9 to the fourth and you
can double-check the 10 to the 4th minus
9 to the 4th is 34 39
so now with that practice using the
basic summon product rules we can start
applying and thinking about the by jet
fuel so the by jet rule simply says that
if I have a by jek ssin between two sets
a and B then they have the same size at
least assuming that they're finite sets
and the only kind of things we're
counting are finite sets let's use an
example of that where I'm gonna count
the number of subsets of a set a by
finding a bijection between the subsets
of a set a and something that I do know
how to count in fact we've already
counted them the binary strings of a
given length
what's the bisection well suppose that a
is a set of n elements called them a 1
through a n and I have some arbitrary
subset of set of a say it's got a 1 and
it doesn't have a 2 and it has a 3 and
it has a 4 and it doesn't have a 5 and
then it's got some selection of the
other numbers and it turns out it has a
in in it okay well if I think of a
subset laid out this way up against the
corresponding elements in a I can code
this in an obvious way by putting a 1
where the element is in the subset and a
0 where the element is not in the subset
in effect this is the so-called
characteristic function of the subset
where 1 means that that index element a
1 in the ice position means that AI is
there and a 0 in the ice position means
that AI is not there so the second
coordinate here is a 0 that means a 2 is
not there and this is easily seen to be
a bisection that is given the string you
can figure out what the subset is given
the subset you can figure out what the
unique string is so we have a bisection
and what we conclude then is that the
number of n bit strings is equal to the
size of power set of a it's equal to the
number of subsets of a and of course we
know how to count the number of n bit
strings it's 2 to the N so what we just
figured out is if I have a set of size
and it's got two to the N subsets and
slick way to say that without mentioning
n is that the size of the power set of a
is simply to to the size of a one more
example of by Jackson counting that it's
kind of fun and an interesting and will
illustrate the fact that we learn
something by finding a by dejection even
if we don't know how to count either one
yet so what I'm interested in is suppose
I have a situation where there are five
kinds of Donuts five different flavors
of Donuts and I want to sort of select a
dozen I want to know how many selections
there are so for example these little
O's represent Donuts I might choose a
selection of a dozen by choosing two
chocolate and no lemon I don't like
those so much and six sugars and two
glazed in two plain
so there are 12 Donuts here using four
out of the five possible flavors of
Donuts this is what I'll call a
selection of a donut and I'd like to
know how many such selections of donuts
are there well let that be the set a the
set of all these different ways of
selecting 12 Donuts when there are five
flavors of Donuts available well there's
an again an obvious correspondence
between the set a of donut selections
and the set B of zeros and ones of
length 16 that contain four ones
what's the correspondence well here's my
donut selection of course the reason why
I use those O's for donuts is that they
also correspond to zeros I can just put
in ones as the limiters between the
groups of flavors so after the the
chocolate donuts I put a one and then
after the lemon donuts that happen to be
none I put another one and then after
the six sugar donuts I put a one and and
then I kind of consolidate and I extract
from the donut selection this 16-bit
word with twelve zeros corresponding to
12 Donuts and four ones corresponding to
breaking up those groups of zeros into
five categories five slots corresponding
to the number
doughnuts of each flavor so the general
bisection of course is that if I have a
selection of see chocolate doughnuts
l-lemon doughnuts as sugar the G glaze
than P plain of any number really the
that a selection of donuts with this
number of chocolates lemons glazed plain
corresponds to a binary word with C plus
L plus s plus G Plus P zeroes and four
ones and so what we can say is that the
set of sixteen digit words with four
ones is exactly the same size as the
number of doughnuts selections even
though at this moment we don't know how
to count either one we will see in the
next lecture an easy way to count the
number of those 16-bit words with four
ones but for now our conclusion from by
ejection counting is that these two sets
are the same size even though I haven't
counted yet either one